and that's where we're going to begin
today because our thoughts are with Alan
Texas this morning they're calling for
prayers again in another city eight
people were killed as you've heard seven
others were wounded in that mass
shooting at a Premium Outlets mall in
the Dallas suburb before a police
officer who happened to be there on
another call kill the gunman Joshua
Barnwell was shopping at the outlets
with a friend on Saturday and we are
very grateful and grateful is the word
that he can join us today Joshua by the
way is the U.S Navy veteran and
immediately rushed to help the victims
Joshua it is so good to see you
thank you so much
so I'm thinking when you went to the
mall on Saturday there's no way you
thought you would be sitting here on
national TV talking to us about this
Monday morning so take us to that moment
when did you realize it was gunshots and
realize we have a problem here
so I was walking with my friend uh
Pastor one store and uh
when we had reached uh
a particular location I'd heard two pops
go off and at that time I was unsure I
looked over towards the north of me and
I'd seen uh what looked like you know
adolescence running so briefly I thought
it might have been a prank
but then uh nearly instantly after that
the massive rapid gun fire began to
occur and at that point I uh
just shy of through my friend behind a
concrete uh pillar a covering support
for the uh the walkway and got behind
there myself and was uh basically
shouting at anybody that was around me
to take cover to get down
and while I was behind this wall I uh
went to dial 9-1-1 I got through to
9-1-1 and let them know what was
happening
and uh after uh I was disconnected from
9-1-1 I sent out an SOS message on my
phone to my emergency contacts leaving a
voicemail uh basically you know we're
down we're under Fire right now we're
okay mass shooting to that respect was
the voicemail that went out when this
first occurred
I know but Joshua let's just let's just
stop on that for a second you're in the
middle of a mass shooting for most
people it's just a story we read on the
news and then people go on to the next
thing I've heard you say it's important
that people hear the details of how
horrible this is because I don't really
think people understand how horrible
this is can you can you share that part
of the story from your perspective
so we went when when when we uh
initially had believed that the uh the
situation had subsided or ended and I
made my way North across the parking lot
because there was just something that I
can't explain that was like I want to go
to where I believe
uh this gunfire had came from and so I
was walking towards what would be the
the h m store and I saw the the glass
that had been completely obliterated and
shot out and that's when I looked over
and I initially there was an area where
uh a landscape area right next to that
store and I saw a woman who was
literally you know folded over where she
had uh been shot and killed and
basically just fell over you know
basically where the term uh you know
dead where they lie come from and then
after I had noticed her I then saw
another man who was shot in the shoulder
that was on the ground and struggling
and next to him was a small child
approximately seven to eight years old
who was lying there and I wasn't sure if
uh she was still with us
next to her was an adult female who was
very heavily wounded and then draped
onto her close to her head was another
young female face down
and then not far from her adjacent to
her feet was another adult male shot
and he was on top of a uh uh adult
female who was by all appearances at
that time already deceased and there was
an approximately five to six year old
young man who was just covered from head
to toe in blood
and what I would later learn the blood
of his mother and his father
um and so I I immediately went to the
the conscious woman who had requested
that I uh attend to her daughter
and I um
looked over and uh their daughter who
appeared almost at that point to already
be what we call a toxic but I did
started doing chest compressions and
mouth to mouth when I did that the
amount of blood that came out of her
backside because her front side appeared
clear but the amount of blood that came
out of her backside was was unbelievable
and I knew at that time that uh that she
had left us
yes yes Joshua you were talking about
this very coherently I know that you're
a Navy veteran so you may be used to
this kind of thing but most of us honest
to God I've never seen a dead body I've
never seen anybody shot and you
certainly don't expect to see this at
the friggin Mall you know you're going
to the mall you don't expect that so how
are you processing this how has it
changed you if at all
it gives me chills just listen to what
you're telling us
I tend to turn to basically to just a
pure logic uh in a situation like this I
try to take out any emotion personally
and just let it process through my mind
in a logical format even though it
appears illogical because it yeah I find
the logic in it and that's how I'm
coping
well now that you're a member of the
unable to communicate
well now that well we appreciate you
sharing what you're sharing as horrible
as it is to see to hear and now that
you've been through it
what do you think it will take I mean
it's a on ongoing conversation nobody
seems to know the answer to this
question
but now that you've been through it and
you've seen up close and personal
I know if there is any magic pill I mean
uh we can speculate Till Dawn whether or
not I mean it seems obvious that there's
obvious uh lee uh mental health problems
that that need to be addressed that have
been long overlooked uh but uh as far as
any other magic pill that's going to
cure this I couldn't tell you and I
wouldn't want to speculate
did you think you were safe at the mall
when you went out with your friend that
morning did you think that you were safe
in a safe place
of course of course you know I'm at a a
very nice small and a very respectable
area that's that's not known for you
know any acts of violence or any
anything even remotely close to this so
yeah naturally this was the third stop
for the day we hadn't had any problems I
didn't really uh
think that you know anything was going
to occur outside of the normal
why did you want to share your story
with us this morning Joshua
well because they're uh traditionally
speaking it's very difficult for to get
somebody who could uh not only who was
there who was really there firsthand in
the action but who where there is
um
a way to communicate without the emotion
so that people can understand the the
true depth of the brevity and and My
Hope in that they have that
understanding of really how far and how
bad it got that there'll be a greater
emotion and hopefully with that emotion
and that understanding
maybe we can Edge you know towards some
sort of uh
uh end you know a goal to where we can
maybe start to to stop this kind of
action
yeah depravity is the word how are you
changed by this did you sleep last night
I did sleep last night
um but and I couldn't tell you now uh
necessarily how it may or may not change
me going forward uh I can't predict that
but I would be astonished if you know
again my already normally
uh overly observant self uh it becomes
even more observant and more conscious
even more so than I already was and I
always have been about my surroundings
Joshua thank you so much I know you
rushed in to help people we certainly
appreciate that and really appreciate
you taking the time to talk to us this
morning I'm glad you're all right now
thank you thank you very much I
appreciate that